es geht ziemlich komisches video heute
schon mal vorab
weil ich muss das ganze als montag
aufnehmen weil ich muss in 45 minuten
aus dem haus gehen nimmt dieses
wochenende in berlin und gut ist nicht
so dass ich ferien habe und eigentlich
den ganzen tag zeit habe aber irgendwie
unkreativ was sie aufnehmen sollte weil
irgendwie darüber kann ich ein bisschen
quatschen
darüber bin ich mir letzter zeit ein
bisschen unsicher weil irgendwie ich mag
minecraft und so und ich hab's anders zu
spielen
nur ist es so ich denke mir so okay was
nimmst jetzt auf und dann überlegt sehr
solcher ist minecraft pvp aufnehmen und
was dann mein problem ist dabei ist halt
einfach ich denke mir so jo du hast
jetzt falsch 700 videos oder sowas
online auf dem kanal und davon ist fast
jedes minecraft pp und irgendwie ist das
ein bisschen kreativ das habe ich auch
in letzter zeit so ein bisschen
herumprobiert deshalb lieber schnell
mitbekommen dass ich da einfach mal ein
paar andere sachen gemacht habe und ja
deshalb bin ich im moment so ein
bisschen am harder mit mir und um mich
immer schwierig so etwas aufzunehmen so
jetzt wenn ihr offenbar läuft kein
problem damit mich wird es auch echt
interessieren was ihr dazu denkt denkt
ihr ceo bring mir lieber mehr meinen
kräften wieder
oder ist doch voll cool gewesen um das
nicht gebracht hast alles und wenn ich
jetzt oben auf dem dach genau dann
könnte ich erstmal gucken dann probiere
ich jetzt hier unten gleich mitzunehmen
und kämpfen
der typ wir deshalb von zwei seiten
angegriffen würden schon leicht leicht
aber okay sie abschreiben
oh gott das gute kommt also doch nicht
so easy abstauben gerne vor hatte gott
richtig der mensch mit seinem
holzschwerter sind schicken besser als
das scheint wie ich übrigens dank euren
kaum häufig getrennten routen
kommentaren lernen durfte die
hintergrundmusik ist übrigens soll
hier findet ihr den oder einfach so weil
der hat mir seine rechte gegeben und das
ist auch so mein lieblingsrapper okay
das wissen bestimmt alle von euch nur
der hat gesagt ja auch klar dass du
meine musik verwenden musste mich dann
verlinken
ich weiß nicht ob ich das noch eben auf
die schnelle schaffe deshalb ist ihr
zumindest bescheid
ich hoffe mal dass auch die audio
verliehen so etwas passt weil
normalerweise nimmt es mit the city auf
dass ich das einfach anpassen kann und
eigentlich wollten die fragen stellen
als ein aber jetzt habe ich hier so ein
bisschen drüber gequatscht und das kam
so ein bisschen unter zwischen gut
fahren lassen mit hashtag schnell
schnell ist jetzt kommt gerade vor wie
im stream so eigene musik im hintergrund
wird auch wenn die ecostream aber ich
mag es eigentlich nur irgendwie ja ich
bin dumm das streaming ist eine
beziehung zu recht oder pr
ich würde sagen davon könnt ihr euch ein
eigenes bild machen wenn wir den maut
strikt machen also wir fahren jetzt
zusammen für 45 tage nach wales und von
daher könnt ihr euch einfach selbst ein
bild machen und ich glaube ich sage aber
so ich liebe ihn sehr
welches ist dein recht also es glauben
hat nicht richtig viele dass wir
zusammen sind so also diese gerade diese
menschen diesen jüngeren als okay jetzt
kommt wieder hey du hast alle jüngeren
menschen einen keinesfalls gut ist und
probiere ich den mann zu schnecken what
the chedi erschwertes eines drauf hat
dann könnte ich das auch machen wird
bestimmt ob ich hätte können allerdings
aber ich hab' welche route er das mit
nur habe ich irgendwas was ich ihm
entgegensetzen können er kommt oder ein
unheil bewahrt oder hatte schon mal was
am schnäbeln gehört als ob die sind
beide unter einer gewinnt der dritte
teil ich streiten freut sich der dritte
naja nächste frage welches ist denn da
ein lieblingsort zum urlaub machen
lg hat einfach nicht gekämpft und
gewonnen was mein lieblingsort zum
urlaub machen ist also nur wohin fahren
liebe ich halt so weil bisher direkt zu
hause so ist ja auch wichtig beim urlaub
dass man sich zu hause fühlt aber also
dass auf jeden fall mit favorit als
lieblings urlaubsort aber ich würde
schon sagen dass das eigentlich nicht so
oder vater trinkt ganze hier gerade
recht undeutlich gesprochen
ich muss was trinken weil ich huste die
ganze zeit schon besser
mal schauen fragen hast du noch ziele
welche du dieses jahr unbedingt
erreichen möchte
ich bin ja nicht sehr krass moment also
ich bin schon krass mensch nein ich bin
nicht der mensch der sich so krasse
ziele setzt leider das ist eigentlich
gute eigenschaft wenn man ziele
sich häufig setzen die dann auch
verfolgt und einhält aber ich habe mir
jetzt nicht irgendwelche bewussten ziele
gesetzt wo ich mir sagen das musst du
dieses jahr schaffen
da habe ich einfach nicht gemacht also
wenn du das gefühl gut im kopf ich
wollte gerade platzieren es ist heute
nicht mehr darunter vier schwer
das mache hierfür sachen das gebe ich
dabei für geräusche von mir leute übrig
geblieben ist
seht ihr der wanderer noch diamanten
unten hat sich also gelohnt
schon für die us und easy weg pink na
gut falschen ground des todes looping
des todes insgesamt gateway leider ich
mache die ganze zeit sofort die dummen
aber erst skateboard longboard oder
penny bord zurzeit fahre ich alles im
team wenig ich bin aber schon sehr lange
zeit bin ich dings gefangen kleiner
dummkopf
es tut man so als hätte ich nichts mehr
vielleicht macht er das noch weiter ist
aber recht schlau die taktik gesehen ich
hätte auch sachen die er werfen kann
eigentlich finde ich das richtig haft so
mit schneebällen zu spielen also wenn
ihm haben gegen mich spielen fünf das
richtig scheiße jetzt gerade mit lava
ausräuchern ist nur fünf spieler
das wäre peinlich leute die wegen einer
baustelle neurone wie sieht es mit der
uhr aus noch das wird richtig knapp
alles naja mal sehen was wir da was
machen kann
vom wasser das stück als kind früher
angst vor dem wir es keine angst mehr
vor der sauna bei meinem vater habe ich
jetzt keine angst mehr vor weil ich
dachte früher immer das in der sauna der
teufel drin wunsch lasst mich in ruhe
aber das ist irgendwie voll ausgeprägt
und seine familie meine kleine schwester
hatte dann ganz lange zeit vor der vor
der uhr die in der sauna hängt also ich
weiß nicht wir sind irgendwie sauna
familie kommt damit klar
ich liebe das irgendwie tonne
jetzt kriegt man schon schaden
vielleicht war es nicht erstaunlich
diese achsen ob vielleicht war das nicht
so schlau diesmal homann
schade dass ich diesmal nicht schneidet
und wäre so ein perfektes drittel
gewesen deshalb drops an die leute die
es bisher gesehen haben angenehm schon
neun minuten auf wie wir einfach nur
viel also ich noch viel
jetzt werde ich einfach mal all in gehen
und dann klicke ich direkt aber
hochladen von interoute erhalten ja ich
bin so was ist das nutzt sich mit jack
betrügt und dazu das alte bild von
dieser ruhm für ja ich weiß schon dass
es ein altes bild ist auf einigen
betrügt man könnte das so cool
zusammenschneiden jetzt gerade ich mich
richtig auf das ist hier auch hüpfen
himmel wo man freunde wenn ihr gehört
daraus einen zusammenschnitt machen will
kann das bestimmt verwenden für seine
westhoff der brody macht es bestimmt
kannst du nicht begrüßen in dem video
fakt diesen listen shut out wurde wurde
das kabinett repräsentiere
soviel dazu so werde die mit wieder in
die luft springt mir scheissegal was ich
alle sagte hautsch ordentlich drauf mit
selber gucken
schade irgendwie runter beim pony das
klapphandy dass irgendjemand runterfällt
aber ich mache fast immer wieder naja
damit kollege ist noch unglaublich
ich hasse das wenn man zwei gold- äpfel
ist irgendwie mit diesem dummen back das
habe ich vorher häufig collection wird
man nichts sehen können und erst sogar
eine etappe besser kann es doch gar
nicht laufen freuen
ich komme mir vor wie im livestream
gerade so immer dieses leichter aus dem
bild klicken und so eine scheiße war
cool
vielleicht sollte ich einfach stream
radfahrer streaming irgendwie aber ob
ich das machen werde
ach leute ok slums ich bin einfach
scheiße heute hh so was ist also
zellmann okay es war schon lustig
verdient okay bei rift denn du siehst
ich [ __ ] deine okay das war echt toll
an gewesen ich hätte es rausgeschnitten
eigentlich ich nehme es zurück und da
will ich sagen leute dass lassen heute
nacht gut bis zum nächsten mal